Hi, I'm Roman,
and I wrote an app
that serves terabytes
of beautiful paintings
across hundreds of thousands
of Android homescreens
every month.
Building the server
took me a little over
a week, only 200 or so
lines of server code
and the power of the
Google Cloud platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I designed and built the
Muzei Live Wallpaper app
with the goal of bringing
beauty and inspiration
to people's
homescreens everyday.
Now let's be fair.
I'm not a rock star
back-end developer.
Far from it.
I design and build
android apps, so the cloud
is kind of a nebulous
thing for me.
I know things like distributed
computing, load balancing,
and network security
are important.
But I'd rather spend
time finessing the pixels
than learning how to fine-tune
Apache, Linux, and MySQL
configs.
Heck, I bet some
of you are laughing
at the mere fact I
just mentioned the LAMP
stack in a video about
cloud computing in 2014.
So if I can build a robust and
scalable back-end, so can you.
Let's take a look at how App
Engine made this possible.
Now a big part of the
app's architecture
relies on a back-end server
that most users of the app,
over 100,000 at the
moment, will hit
every day between 2:00
AM and 2:20 AM GMT
to get the latest artwork.
With App Engine, the first
few real lines of code
give me a basic,
yet fully scalable,
data store ready to go.
30 or so lines later, and
my database query logic
and conversion to JSON for
the primary endpoint was done.
Another 20 lines of memcache
and HTTP caching code,
and I now had a
well-oiled machine, easily
capable of handling hundreds
of thousands of requests
during the 20 minute
refresh window.
I also wrote a tiny
content management system
to let me queue up artwork
for weeks at a time.
It was only another 100 or
so lines of App Engine code,
mostly Ajax style end points
used by a single html page.
One of my favorite
aspects here was
that adding a single
line to my YAML config
gave me instant security and
the comfort that my CMS was
protected from
would-be intruders.
There's one last thing.
I'm serving two
terabytes of images
per month, where
most of the artwork
comes from the wonderful
WikiPaintings.org project.
Now I really want to be
a good citizen of the web
and avoid melting
their servers, so I
grab the images I
need and mirror them
into Google Cloud Storage.
This way my app can scale
to millions of users,
and the fine folks
at WikiPaintings.org
don't have to carry the burden.
The best thing is this is
fully integrated into my CMS.
I simply give it a
WikiPaintings link,
and it reads the page
metadata, creates a thumbnail,
and stores the images
in Google Cloud Storage.
All the service-side
code for that
fits in a single screenful
on my 30-inch monitor.
Coming from a UI guy
who doesn't really
like dealing with messy things
like servers and back-ends,
the whole thing is
kind of beautiful.
So there it is.
To build my back-end, I
only needed a small amount
of Python code and was
able to leave the rest up
to Google because of App
Engine and cloud storage.
I don't really have to
stay up at night worrying
about servers melting
or databases going down.
And that makes me truly a
happy Android developer.
So go forth and start building
your next great scalable
app now.
You can look at all the
source code for Muzei
and use it for inspiration
or as a starting
point for your next great app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]